canadian prime minister justin trudeau
is very concerned about freedom in
ukraine
western intelligence agencies believe
russia will invade ukraine any day now
and so trudeau has announced that he
will be giving ukraine a half billion
dollar loan and an additional 7.8
million dollars worth of military
equipment it is even possible that we
will see canadian soldiers fighting
alongside other nato allies in ukraine
to repel putin's invading force so
crucial is it to western civilization
that we maintain freedom
in ukraine and to prepare for this
robust defense of freedom in eastern
europe justin trudeau is making sure to
quash every last gasp of freedom in his
own country
in response to the peaceful convoy of
truckers protesting the government's
vaccine mandate trudeau has officially
suspended civil liberties in canada
federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades and
occupations it is now clear
that responsible leadership
requires us to do this
these measures must be and will be
compliant with our charter of rights and
freedoms indeed the emergencies act was
created in the late 80s to flow from and
uphold the charter
we'll always
defend the rights of canadians to
peaceful assembly and to freedom of
expression here in our capital city
families small businesses have been
enduring illegal obstruction of their
neighborhoods
occupying streets
harassing people breaking the law
this is not
a peaceful protest
blm riots that's mostly peaceful but
truckers honking to avoid injecting
themselves with an experimental drug of
dubious moral and medical value that
is terrorism this sort of law last
invoked by trudeau's father when he was
the leader of canada will allow the
suspension of public assembly travel and
the use of property it will allow the
government to force privately owned tow
truck companies to do the government's
bidding and take the trucks
it will even freeze and seize the
financial assets of the truckers and the
truckers supporters
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money lauder laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
regular old truckers who don't want to
inject themselves needlessly with an
experimental drug are having their
rights their way of life and their
property taken from them in canada the
nicest smiliest most pleasant liberal
nation
on earth
and i'm supposed to be worried about a
territorial battle in one of the most
frequently conquered countries in the
history of the world
i don't want to sound callous and i am
sure vladimir putin is a no good dirty
rotten terrible guy
but how exactly are we supposed to
defend freedom on the other side of the
world when we can't even preserve it in
america's hat
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music who says
biden told sam brinton
the dogma
lives loudly within you sam brinton
being the nuclear official who is
apparently a dog fetishist
really great work there from that
commenter love me a good pun
especially especially a pun
about the absolute degradation of our
federal government it's really a it gets
you tense when you think about
how
degraded and weakened our country and
our government have become and when
you're just feeling so tense it's nice
to
relax sit back and enjoy one of the
finest sofas you can ever get that would
be all form if you've been listening to
this show for a while you have certainly
heard me talk about my helix mattress i
love my helix mattress it is absolutely
magnificent mattress built just for you
it's so beautiful
well helix has left the bedroom and now
moved into the family room the living
room they've started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form they are already making the
greatest sofas we have ever seen
so what makes an all-form sofa really
really great for starters it is the
easiest way that you can customize a
sofa using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
and shape to make sure
that it is absolutely perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move as your family changes
it's really really top-notch stuff i
love it if you think it sounds a little
risky don't worry you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it that is
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free give you
a full refund but you're going to love
it they've got a forever warranty a
forever warranty but you're going to
love it find your perfect sofa check out
allforum dot com knowles all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners that's allform.com
justin trudeau in canada is clamping
down he is doubling down he is calling
these truckers terrorists he is saying
you will take the fouchy ouchy you will
inject yourselves even though everything
we told you about it all the promises we
made turned out not to be totally true
even though the virus is not nearly as
dangerous as the fear mongers initially
said it was still you've got to do it
it's almost as though this isn't about a
virus it's almost as though this isn't
about the public health or a pandemic
it's almost as though this is just about
an exercise of power a resetting of the
political order and the economy and and
justin trudeau asserting himself just
like so many politicians in america have
asserted themselves saying no we're
going to grab this power in in the new
normal that's what trudeau is doing now
the
little glimmer of hopes the silver
lining in canada is that where power is
closer to the people where power is more
accountable to the people you are seeing
not a doubling down on the mandates but
a loosening up you're seeing for
instance in ontario
the ontario premier doug ford who is
also significantly more conservative
than justin trudeau he's just announced
that the mandates are gone they're going
the way of the dodo the vaccine passport
system will be shut down on march 1st
capacity limits on restaurants bars
theaters and gyms will be lifted this
week that'll be on thursday a week ahead
of schedule he said that the the reason
for the lifting of these uh restrictions
has absolutely nothing to do with the
truckers
has nothing to do no way not with the
freedom convoy this is purely
science he says they would never
negotiate with people who are breaking
the law i am a little
skeptical of that because
while we're told by all the public
health geniuses that they're going to
just follow the science and the science
the science hasn't changed
the science hasn't changed one little
bit
these
lockdowns these mandates these vaccine
passport requirements have been
implemented at various times throughout
america and throughout canada but
they've really ramped up within the last
month or so
and then all of a sudden they went away
ahead of schedule most of the time when
when the mandates weren't simply
indefinite so what changed
not
the medical science but the political
science even fauci has admitted this all
the public health leaders have admitted
this
the re they are calibrating their public
health pronouncements to what they think
the people can take and they're basing
it much more on what they think people
will do rather than on any sort of
epidemiology this this was true from the
very beginning when fauci said don't
wear the masks the masks don't work and
then five seconds later he said you have
to weigh the masks the masks are really
great and then later on they said
actually the masks don't really do all
that much and the world leaders
themselves never really took the mask
seriously just look at the super bowl
all the plebes who had to work at the
super bowl they had their masks on all
of the rich wealthy powerful elites who
were at the super bowl none of them were
wearing their masks because they never
really believed it either it was always
about controlling people you even had
this with the the shortening of the
coronavirus quarantine
happened just within the last month they
said okay we're no longer going to make
you quarantine for 10 days it's going to
be five days why did the did the virus
suddenly get lethargic and lazy and it's
no longer infecting people no they just
knew that people weren't going to do it
and fouchy even said that at a certain
point you got to figure out what people
are going to do and so they weren't
going to do it anymore and so he changed
the policy this is all about the
truckers good job truckers honk honk
love what you're doing you are defending
not just some abstract liberty but the
way of life in canada and you're seeing
this here too you want to talk about a
silver lining
down in dc
here one of the most draconian public
health regimes
that we've seen anywhere in the country
i was in dc about a month ago for the
march for life and
almost every place you would go into was
demanding your papers your medical
history your id it was really really
intense
some people pushed back against that
sort of thing
this was being reflected in the poll
numbers and all of a sudden even dc
is lifting the mandates
additionally
beginning tomorrow february 15th
as you know the public health emerge the
limited public health emergency that i
put in effect in december
expires
as will the requirement for indoor
venues
to verify that patrons are vaccinated
again businesses may choose to keep
vaccination requirements in their place
in place
at their establishment
with appropriate signage
i love this woman the mayor of dc she's
trying to make it sound like this is
just the ordinary way of things and
they're going to expire
and you know the science
lady these mandates have only been
enforced for for a month now
what do you mean there and now they're
so they're just going to expire now no
do you know what's happening is that the
democrats know they're in an election
year they see that these mandates are
absolutely crushing them in the polls
and so they're doing a complete 180.
and for a while at the beginning of the
mandates the mass mandates and the
vaccine mandates you saw from the
mainstream news media they would they
tried to
insist that the public actually loved
these mandates and they'd cook up a
bunch of numbers and say they're polling
really well you know how you know
they're not polling well because all the
democrats are doing a 180 now that's how
you know it's not working is the people
are pushing back against this stuff and
we still have enough of a functioning
republic in this country that these
sitting politicians are nervous that the
people are going to throw the bums out
if they don't lighten up and let them
return to their ordinary way of life
now one political issue that has not
gotten any easier recently are these
soaring gas prices but luckily
there is a solution that would be get
upside i had to fill up my tank this
morning my tank was low i now wait for
it to get very very low
because gas is going through the roof
even here in beautiful nashville gas is
way way up from what it was last year
thank you
mr president and so
there was a little silver lining in my
storm cloud of having to fill up my tank
do you know what that was
get upside get upside is so simple you
download the free get upside app you use
promo code knowles canon wles
and you will get 25 cents per gallon
cash back that's right there's no cash
only cash back goes straight to your
bank account or if you prefer through
paypal or you get an amazon gift card or
a gift card to some other online company
it's really straightforward i would
recommend it going straight to your bank
account
you download the app
it's it's free app use the promo code
knowles
you will get 25 cents per gallon or more
on your first tank get upside users all
over the u.s are earning over a million
dollars cash back every single week cash
out anytime head on over the free get
upside app
promo code knowles you can thank me with
all your savings according to
a new poll the majority of democrats do
not want joe biden to run again in 2024.
who do you think put this poll out
because you're going to hear from the
left they're going to say oh this is
propaganda oh this is just right-wing
conspiracy nonsense who do you think put
the poll out you think it was the daily
wire
you think it was the blaze you think it
was fox news you think it was
cnn baby cnn says the majority of
democrats do not want joe biden to run
again in 2024.
only 45 percent
of democrats and democrat leaning voters
want biden to run for re-election 51
percent want someone else to run
margin of error is 3.3 points this is
really devastating news for joe biden i
was
having
a drink with a liberal family member of
mine
uh just about a week ago he says to me
michael
who
who are we gonna get i said who's we he
said we democrats who are we gonna get
there's no way biden can run again right
i said i don't what's the alternative
kamala harris is less popular than biden
the democrats keep trying to make poop
buddage happen
just like the mean girls try to make
fetch happen it's not going to happen
he's not i know i'm i know he was
created in a lab probably in the cia
building at langley i know he checks all
the boxes he's glib he's good looking
he's gay he went to harvard he worked
him i know
he's he seems great on paper but it's
he's not going to happen guys buddha
judge is not good so then who do you
have you've got uh
anthony blinken the secretary of state i
don't think so yeah after botching every
foreign issue during his tenure you've
got uh
liz warren is she still i don't think
she's a thing anymore who do you have
you got nothing and so the majority of
even democrats don't want this guy to
run joe biden and yet he's probably the
best option they've got the one other
option
and they're already floating this doug
shone a former clinton advisor ran an
op-ed in the wall street journal about a
month or so ago floating this idea
what if
they reanimate the corpse of hillary
clinton
what if they go back and have hillary
3.0 well there's even worse news there
for democrats john mclaughlin who was a
pollster who worked for trump but he's a
very respected pollster on both sides of
the aisle john mclaughlin just ran a
poll
trying to figure out how trump would
fare against any democrat candidate in
2024 here's what he found
our last national poll joe biden has a
57 job disapproval that's a drop of 33
points since last april i mean last
april he had a 50 58 percent approve
trump had left them with the growing
economy
vaccines people thought things were
going to get better and senate instead
they spent they had he didn't have to do
anything donald trump defeats joe biden
nationally in these polls 49-44
and and trump defeats campbell harris
even worse 51-40 and he even beat
hillary clinton 51-41
so the republicans are united and for
this november the republicans are
leading in the generic ballot for
congress 48-43
it's just absolutely devastating news
for the democrats
it's sort of devastating news as well
for the non-trump republicans
because you hear a lot of talk right now
about especially ron desantis he's
considered to be the sort of young gun
shiny new thing who could be a great
brand i think he could be a good
presidential candidate but the hurdle
that he's going to have to overcome is
that donald trump is just dominating the
field you will sometimes hear anti-trump
people in the democrats and in the
republican party who say well trump's
only commanding the support of 53
percent of republicans
oh is that all
only 53 percent
you look at the next candidate ron
desantis who's a great governor who's
doing a good job who probably could be a
good presidential candidate he's at
something like 13
the other the other candidates also who
would be superb presidential candidates
you look at someone like ted cruz you
look at someone like mike pompeo you
look
you go down the list
all of all of them are at 13 or less
trump is at 53. because you got to
remember for people who are tuning into
shows like this
you are very politically aware
you are i'm this is not just flattery if
you're tuning into a show like this you
know what's going on in politics you
know who the players are you know what
the stakes are you know what the
official message is you know what the
reality is but the vast majority of
americans do not spend their time
thinking about these things
they don't
there i i just spoke to a young woman
perfectly bright ordinary well-adjusted
young woman
who i mentioned dr fauci she said who's
dr fauci i said lucky you blessed are
you that you are not paying so much
attention to what's going on that you
don't
you don't know who dr fauci is that's
great so when you think of ordinary
people who are just going about their
lives who are not concerned about
i don't know what's going on in ukraine
this week or what this particular law in
canada means for this for ordinary
people who are just kind of paying
attention to their jobs and their family
and their local communities
what's the name you're going to think of
is trump now the good news for the
republicans is trump is absolutely
crushing every other candidate right now
and the house republicans
are are absolutely crushing the
democrats
so
how do we lose how do we lose well
republicans can still lose and the
reason they can still lose is that
republicans do not have any
institutional power
the liberals control
every single center of power in this
country
except for the people
that's what that's what the trucker
thing is about
that's what the anti-vaxx anti-mask
anti-public health establishment
protests are about in america
it's what the freedom convoys about in
france for goodness sakes they've got a
trucker protest in france right now
what's it about it's especially
pronounced here in america
we don't control the universities
we conservatives we don't control the
media we don't control big tech
we don't control corporations we don't
control sports we don't control the
government we don't control the
bureaucracy
we don't control the ngos we don't
control the transnational institute we
don't control any of it but we still
have a lot of the people
we still have roughly half the people
probably more than half the people if
these polls are to be believed
and that's what's creating
this friction that's what's creating
this tension but i'll show you how it
played out
do you remember years ago now
the new york times blamed sarah palin
for a mass shooting
they blam because sarah palin
had it put out some totally normal
political material saying these are the
districts we're targeting these are the
policies that we're targeting in in our
political actions in this coming
election cycle
right and that that word and that image
of the target then later on uh
congressman gabby giffords democrat
congressman gets shot she ended up
surviving but she ends up getting shot
and the left blames sarah palin because
she used this image of targeting
districts everyone uses it democrats use
it republicans use it they've always but
they they found a cynical opportunity
and they said sarah palin's responsible
and sarah palin sued the new york times
for defamation
well unfortunately
palin sued the new york times in a new
york court the the jury was deliberating
on this case it seems like a pretty
strong case to me
and then the judge while the jury was
deliberating
threw out the case
and the judge in this liberal new york
court said asari the palin team has not
has not proved that that the the what
the new york times did reach this very
high standard for defamation and the
judge is right about
two things
he's right about one there is a very
high standard for defamation in this
country there wasn't always a very high
standard for defamation but there is now
and two what the judge said was the the
palin team did not prove actual
malice meaning even if the new york
times
is extremely ignorant and extremely
irresponsible that the new york times
there's no proof that the new york times
actually knew that the stupid nonsense
that they were publishing was was false
and so
the defense is basically look the new
york times they're a bunch of idiots how
are they supposed to know the new york
times they're totally ignorant they
don't know anything about what's going
on
so because you because you can't prove
that the new york times has even two
brain cells to rub together therefore
it's not defamation
which is a fairly strong case when
you're talking
when you're talking about the new york
times
now the reason for this the reason that
the threshold is so high for defamation
is because there was a court case in
1964 new york times versus sullivan it
actually involved the new york times
again because they're extremely
irresponsible journalists
and in that case the liberal court
decided to raise the standard immensely
for defamation to this standard of
actual malice and so for all intents and
purposes you a public figure cannot sue
for defamation no matter how
irresponsible and vicious the coverage
is in other countries it's pretty easy
and sometimes public figures do win but
not here in america not since the 1960s
conservatives need to cut this out there
is an impulse among conservatives to say
look we want we need to protect the
freedom of the press to such a degree
that they should be able to publish
whatever nonsense lies about politicians
that's the only way to preserve free
speech in america bs that's not going to
help us here folks all that does this
very high standard from the 1960s of
defamation all it does is entrench
liberal power because the liberals
control all of these institutions
especially the press
trump was aware of this other
conservatives who know what time it is
are aware of this we need to tighten up
those libel laws those defamation laws
otherwise all we are doing is handing
the left more and more and more power in
a way that is unjust and completely
unnecessary and will not will not help
anyone in this country in the will not
will not help the country overall it'll
help the liberals but it won't help the
country overall in the long run if you
missed the world premiere of shut-in
this past weekend head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe and get a
membership today
the film is now exclusively streaming
for daily wire members it currently has
a critic score of 100 and an audience
score of 97
on rotten tomatoes we are creating more
and more great entertainment without a
leftist agenda it's all thanks to our
daily wire members head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe today so you can
watch shut in hyperions and gina
carano's new movie out this summer also
when it comes to understanding how our
world is run there's always more to
uncover introducing one of the daily
wires newest projects the enemy within
our new series featuring acclaimed
journalist lee smith author of the plot
against the president in his newest
project smith uncovers a political coup
orchestrated by america's ruling elites
to generate their own wealth and power
at the expense of the american people's
safety and freedom the enemy within will
start streaming this friday exclusively
at daily wire also if you're a candace
owens fan well yes we candice
merchandise is back in stock and ready
for your shopping pleasure she's also
added brand new merch that is very
limited when she launched the line in
december her initial merch release sold
out in just two days don't wait where
this collection might be gone again
check it out at yeswecandus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
sometimes conservatives defend
the insanely left-wing radical
unfair irresponsible press
they will they oppose tightening up
defamation laws and the reason they do
it is they say well
you know if we tighten up defamation
laws
then the government might use that to
suppress our speech
then the liberals might use that to
silence us
as though the liberals weren't already
silencing us using all the power that
they've got not just through the
government but through the whole
public private establishment big tech
the corporations the universities
all corporate america all of it just
they're already doing that so these
people are worried about a hypothetical
that is already happening in real life
but furthermore what they will say and
it sounds principled even though it's
it's really not a
great principle but what they'll say is
the answer
to bad speech
is more speech
you see look the new york times even if
they're running vicious lies complete
dishonesty
the the the answer to that is not to
tell them no and enforce defamation laws
no no the answer to that is build your
own new york times that's basically what
they're saying right it's more speech
that is not always true
the the answer to
lots of speech is to punish it
right and that has always been the case
in america the if you told the founding
fathers the answer to to bad speech
is more speech they would have looked at
you like you had three heads
the answer to fraud is more speech uh no
the answer to fraud is prosecution
the answer to sedition
and treason
and direct threats
is more speech
no it's a police officer and a judge in
a courtroom that's the answer to those
things the answer to obscenity is well
these days i guess it's more obscenities
what we're doing no do you know what the
founding fathers would have said they
said no the answer to that is a jury and
a judge and the enforcement of our laws
what are you talking about
we want we want a thriving marketplace
of ideas we do we really do want that
but you're not going to get that if
you tolerate all sorts of fraud and lies
and dishonesty and obscenity
actually all that kind of speech is
going to undermine the free marketplace
of ideas as it is right now
you're not you're not going to get the
answer to the bad speech is as more
speech if the liberals control all of
the speech
the liberals control 100
of the institutional speech platforms in
america 100
conservatives don't have any of it
we don't have the the press
we don't have the government
we don't have the big tech platforms
which are the public square right now
we don't have any of it and it's
no surprise that we're now seeing
our
voices being taken away from us
what do we have we have
some podcasts
i'm i'm very fortunate i've got a very
large platform here at the michael
knowles show and at the daily wire
that's great
facebook could turn us off in two
seconds
like well you saw it with joe rogan even
joe rogan man he's the biggest podcaster
in the whole world
what he well he he questioned a few
things about kovid he pointed out some
inconsistencies with dr fauci he brought
on
very well-respected scientists who
happened to dissent from the ruling
class and what happened
they
they fixed him real good
they took off a hundred epis more than
100 episodes of his show they put
disclaimers on the shows that they
didn't like
they don't i listen don't get too rowdy
there
joe rogan joe rogan who's a liberal he's
not even a conservative
so we don't control any of this
when when
conservatives say the answer to bad
speech is more speech it's incoherent in
the particulars
but
it's also impractical in
in real life because we don't have any
of those institutions the one thing
we've got
is the people
that's what you're seeing in canada
that's what you're seeing here the one
power center that we still have at least
some of is the people and so the people
we the people need to use what power we
have to bring our country back into some
semblance of sanity and we can do that
in the market and we can do that in the
culture and yes we need to do that in
politics we the people through our
self-government
you want to talk about irresponsible
journalism
after the super bowl win
the people of los angeles reacted as is
so often the case
when a city wins a super bowl they
torched their own city
there was rioting there was madness
there was mayhem
what better way to celebrate than to
destroy your community
so this was going on in la as everybody
expected and cbs news the local cbs news
affiliate they
they didn't want to make these people
look bad
you know this is these are democrat
voters here who are burning down this
city so they're jumping on cars and
you know causing all sorts of mayhem and
you know riding in the streets
or in the words of cbs they were
engaging in
problematic celebration
that's the new one they say
problematic celebrators were seen
jumping on top of a white pickup truck
as police tried to disperse the crowd
lapd declared an unlawful assembly
almost 45 minutes before
when blm
burns down cities and attacks federal
courthouses and kills dozens of people
and loots and robs and rapes and kills
villages and burns for eight months
that is
a mostly peaceful protest
when
angelinos riot
after the super bowl win and jump on top
of cars and create riots in the streets
that is a problematic celebration
and when ordinary hard-working basically
law-abiding truckers
honk their horns so they don't need to
inject themselves with an experimental
drug
to stave off to possibly to probably not
even stave off a virus that's not all
that dangerous to most people
that's terrorism
that's the world that we're living in
right now okay
that's the world of the journalists
that's the world of the government
that's the world according to both of
them
and it's completely false
and it is an it is nothing more than an
instrument to upend our way of life take
away our rights and our liberties and
everything that we've come to cherish in
these countries
and we've got to push back on that you
want to talk about hollywood you want to
talk about the media for a second this
is a story i was i wasn't going to get
into
because this is not exactly a tabloid
show you know this is not hollywood all
access or anything like that but this
story actually gets to something pretty
important in our politics and culture
i'm talking about yeezy i'm talking
about mr yay
talking about the breakup of kim yay
kim kardashian now dating pete davidson
why i don't know pete davidson pulls
above his weight in the girls i guess
but they're dating kanye was dating some
other girl i guess he's not dating her
anymore it's very sad their marriage was
falling apart but he's still trying to
get back together
kanye west has been going after his
wife's
they're not actually divorced i don't
think so his wife's
current boyfriend p davidson
he uh i won't he's using colorful
language but he posted a picture of pete
davidson who because he got a hillary
clinton tattoo on himself and he said
look at this d-i-c-k head i wonder if
instagram gonna shut down my page for
dissing hillary clinton's ex-boyfriend
then he goes on
uh he keeps posting pictures of pete
davidson and going after him
he says
when i tag people i'm just putting
together the web they're a group of
people who run the media in the election
thank god for free speech so kanye
totally totally right on that point
and uh then
pete davidson apparently sent kanye west
a message and said i'd never get in the
way of your children how you guys want
to raise your kids is your business and
not mine i do hope that one day
i can meet them and we can all be
friends
right hey this is the new boyfriend
saying this to the husband of the woman
that he's dating
and kanye just responds all caps he says
no you will never meet my children
awesome i love that
i love that
we should all learn a lesson from kanye
right now i know that is a
not not necessarily the sort of thing
one would naturally think but kanye is
actually doing something right here
kanye is trying to save his marriage and
he's not just going along with this and
his wife kim kardashian has a whole
spread in vogue about how she's going to
live for herself now remember we covered
it on the show last week she's in her
40s it's about what she wants and she's
not going to let other people tell her
what to do and you know it's fine if her
children are traumatized by her leaving
her husband and by the dissolution of
their marriage and her
engaging in this high profile
fling with this hollywood derelict yeah
that's fine because it's for her it's
about me now and kanye west is saying no
i'm not going quietly i'm not doing this
i'm not going to let you have your own
new life and take my children away from
me
and i'm not going to
pretend that it's all fine and it's all
amicable and it's all good and don't
worry you do you and i'll do me and
we'll all just date whoever we want and
by the way when we get tired of those
people we're going to kick them out too
and we're going to date other people and
if our kids are extremely confused and
traumatized by that well that look
that's just that's just the cost of
pursuing your own appetites and desires
and now we can all be friends hey let's
all get dinner me you and pete davidson
and pete davidson's girlfriend pete
davidson's girlfriend's boyfriend it's
cool it's all good right no kanye's
saying no it's not good
stop acting like a harlot and a trollop
and come back to your husband and we're
going to live together because we made
it an agreement to do this we made a
consequated marriage
vow before the people
of our community and before the public
and before our god and we're going to
honor that
i love it
i love it i don't know if it's going to
work but i love it that's totally the
right attitude
it's totally the right the kim the kim
attitude of i'm just going to do me
don't let people tell you what to do i'm
going to do me and the kanye attitude of
no i'm going to do what i said i would
do and i'm going to live up to even
though i'm a extremely broken flawed
sinful person i am going to try to be
virtuous and holy and
it it that's not just you do you and
i'll do me and no we're we're going to
do what we should do and what we're
supposed to do
and we're going to defend if we're going
to have a good life and a good country
and a good society we're going to defend
the basic political institution the
family marriage
and
and i'm not going to let some scruffy
hair derelict from saturday night live
get in the way of that
absolutely right stand up kanye kim
should go back to her husband
we should we should
we should tighten up these sorts of
things you know
there's been a movement
on the right in recent years away from
the sort of you do you kind of hey
whatever just if it feels good do it
just cut my taxes just don't make me pay
for it right there's been a movement
away from that a movement toward more
traditional social values a movement
toward defending the nation right toward
borders toward
and one of the parts of this movement
has been
that we should tighten up divorce laws
that the idea of no fault divorce which
took hold in the latter part of the 20th
century has been a disaster and it's led
to family mayhem and it's led to all
sorts of social pathologies and we
shouldn't have it
it should be harder to get divorced
on the one hand
it sounds like you're taking away
freedom when you do that right what do
you mean people don't have the freedom
to just get divorced whenever they want
i know it sounds like that but
making divorce harder to get
making the threshold much higher is
actually a way to expand freedom
i think about it this way think about it
with a national border we don't have
really borders in this country anymore
certainly not our southern border people
just pour across by the millions
every year so it sounds like that's that
gives you more freedom right this
america is much more free we don't even
have borders anymore but actually
america is much less free because we
don't have the border because we don't
have that constraint because we no
longer have the ability to
chart our own national course we no
longer have the stability of a normal
country that actually follows the laws
the the stability and the order
requisite for true liberty to flourish
it's the same thing with the speech laws
if you have free speech quote unquote
protections for fraud and obscenity and
threats and fighting words
then you don't have speech then you've
got bullying and then you've you've got
de facto censorship all in the name of
speech and the same thing with marriage
marriage
constricts your license and your ability
to do whatever you want whenever you
want to do it but it actually expands
your freedom because it gives you a life
it gives you stability it gives you it
gives you trust that you can rely on the
things that people said they were going
to do that they're actually going to do
them it gives you
a good base to grow a family
gives you an ability to do other things
in a very basic level when when you get
married you don't need to worry so much
about who's gonna who's gonna cook and
who's gonna clean and who's gonna do the
dishes and who's gonna pay the bills
you've agreed to that and then you've
moved forward and you're working
together
kanye this
this
reaction this kind of crazy hollywood
reaction to his wife's new boyfriend is
actually probably the
the best argument kanye has made for why
we should elect him president i'm not
saying he should actually be president
but i am saying he is seeing something
politically that we should see as well
we got to get tough we got to we've got
to
put some more boundaries on things if we
want to have true freedom you know
what's good this is actually a perfect
example of this in new york city right
now well in cities around the country
but especially new york
crime is going through the roof
rhyme is going through the roof there
was a horrible story of a man
who just attacked some poor thai woman
on the subway platform this man had 44
previous arrests but he was walking
around free now according to the left
the way to expand freedom is to let the
criminals out of jail and not to arrest
them in the first place
actually i think it would expand the
freedom of this thai woman and every
ordinary citizen of new york if you
threw the criminals in prison restrict
that freedom right restrict that license
you're going to expand freedom for all
of the citizens
this man
it's a hard video to watch
there's a man who just approaches this
woman on the platform and just beats the
living hell out of her a man is in
queens
he's got 44 arrests in his life
charged on thursday for the brutal
mugging in november of this thai woman
which took place in manhattan so it's in
the supposedly the safest borough of new
york
the guy grabbed this woman from behind
dragged her then threw her to the ground
punched her in the face four times then
made off with her purse oh he sexually
assaulted her too by the way
this animal this attacker
should be put away from society
he's an a he's a beast he's an animal he
shouldn't be allowed in free polite
society
i believe in second chances i i really
do
i think people even who commit really
terrible crimes i believe in second
chances i sometimes even believe in
third chances
what i do not believe in is 45th chances
i think 45th chances is a little bit too
far
and by the way
obviously it would have been much better
for this woman that he just brutalized
if this animal had been put in prison
and not allowed out
obviously it would be better for the
people of new york who now they have to
fear for their lives every time they get
on a subway even in manhattan which is
the safe borough
but it would be better for him too
i don't think he's living a particularly
flourishing life
mugging women and engaging in more and
more crime and vice and sin and living
like a filthy disgusting animal
giving away his humanity throwing it
away so that he can take some woman's
dignity and take her purse and run away
and go do it to someone else
i don't think that's good for him i
think it would be much better for him
if he were locked up
being punished being rehabilitated
doing a little introspection maybe and
perhaps even repenting and perhaps even
turning his life around he's not going
to do that on the streets
the only way he's going to do that isn't
is in prison
and and the left won't do it
because and what it really comes down to
is their perverted conception of freedom
i think they really believe like like
rashida talib says you got to abolish
the prisons the reason we have
oppression in america is because we
lock up these animals
people who who mug women and sexually
assault them 44 45 times and because we
lock those people up
that's why we don't have freedom in
america no it's the opposite of course
it's the opposite
so the russians are expected to invade
ukraine
the russians are expected to invade
ukraine tomorrow
will they do it i don't know maybe
they've done it before
they invaded crimea and kept it they
invaded
georgia on george bush's watch bush
repelled them though and so they didn't
they didn't keep georgia so they've done
it before they certainly want to ukraine
has is one of the most conquered
countries in the history of the world
it's been conquered by
the soviets conquered by the the tsarist
russians before the soviets took over
conquered by
the austro-hungarian empire conquered by
the ottoman empire even conquered by the
poles the polls are themselves one of
the most conquered countries on earth
and the polish lithuanian commonwealth
conquered ukraine so are the russians
interested in taking ukraine obviously
are they going to do it
i don't know i don't know that they will
maybe they will maybe they won't i think
a lot of people are skeptical
though that this is going to go down the
way that the state department is
saying that that it's going to go down
i think a lot of people
are
reluctant for war
even if
the
the russians do invade and why
why are they skeptical
because
the united states has squandered its
foreign credibility and it's not just
democrats it's primarily democrats but
it's not just democrats joe biden the
other day
was asked about a new army report that
came out the the army has a report on
the withdrawal from afghanistan and the
report is devastating for the the
political leaders there biden just
completely botched that thing and joe
biden
dismissed the army report does any of
that ring true to you no
no
that's not what i was told
that you were told that the u.s
administration officials were prepared
they knew it was time to get out
no but i was told no one told me that
look there was no good time to get out
but if we had not gotten out they
acknowledged that we would have had to
put a hell of a lot more troops back in
it wasn't just 2 000 4000 we would have
to significantly increase the number of
troops and we were back in this this war
of attrition
and it and there was no way we were ever
going to unite
ukraine i mean excuse me
afghanistan no way that was going to
happen
and so this is a much wiser thing to do
i just want to clarify are you rejecting
the conclusions or the the accounts that
are in this army report yes i am
they're not not true i'm rejecting them
joe biden he says no forget that don't
believe your lying eyes no you've got it
you've got to believe the government
you've got to believe the intelligence
agencies you've got to believe the
pentagon except when they disagree with
me in which case you should never
believe them don't worry afghanistan was
great but it's it's bigger than
afghanistan
what about libya remember when obama
invaded libya for basically no good
reason remember that and then libya got
worse after the invasion remember that
remember
the complete botched foreign policy in
syria
and iraq
remember remember all of
that and now the american people say we
don't want you invading ukraine
and i can't blame them even if there
were a good reason to invade ukraine
even if there were even if the
intelligence agencies had 100 credit
credibility state department 100
credibility the pentagon top brass these
woke political
jerks who are turning our army into a
gender study seminar even if they were
all 100 right
they've squandered their credibility and
so the american people don't really buy
it
and and i think the most devastating
part of all for them
is
the american people are looking around
at our own country and they're saying
hold on we're not enforcing the laws
we've got crime going through the roof
we've got actual insurrections here like
blm burning the country down for eight
months we've got no borders we've got
millions of foreigners pouring across
our border
even if it's for good good reason even
if it's to have a better life even it's
for economic opportunity it is quite
literally an invasion i'm not saying
it's an invasion led by some military
commander but it's people going from
their country that they're supposed to
be in and taking over another country
and they're looking around at that
and they're saying
[Music]
before
before we go over there how about we get
our problems fixed over here
but
i understand
that you might be able to do two things
at once
but in this case i'm not sure that we
can i'm not saying it's not possible in
principle to do two things at once but
what the american people are saying is
what are we doing the american
conception of freedom that we're
supposed to be expanding around the
world what the hell is it i'm not
allowed to go to church i'm not allowed
to work and it's it's much worse in
canada by the way at least in red states
here in america things are
basically back to normal in canada it's
not they're going even further they're
suspending civil liberties
i am i am sure kiev is a great place i'm
sure it's a lovely city i'm sure the
ukrainians are great people i would be
happy to defend the ukrainians if if
vladimir putin is doing anything unjust
against them but if we're talking about
political priorities right now i am much
more interested in liberating ottawa and
washington dc than i am worried about
kiev i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there